hey everyone and welcome to biology
professor before we get started today i
want you to know about something cool
that you have access to i am collecting
pictures
of all of my final board notes so at the
end of the lesson i will take a picture
of this note with everything filled in
and i will put it as a pdf
in a folder that you will have free
access to so if you want a pdf of the
notes of the board at the end just check
out the link in the description to get
that pdf also remember to hit subscribe
and hit the bell for notifications so
you can check out more of my awesome
biology study videos as they come out
so let's go ahead and get started
today's lesson is on three major
components of the cytoskeleton so that's
going to be microfilaments
intermediate filaments and microtubules
we're going to talk about each of those
separately
before we launch into microfilaments
intermediate filaments microtubules i'm
kind of comparing and contrasting them
let's just talk about what cytoskeleton
is for a minute this right here
cytoskeleton it is very complex as you
can see i mean it fulfills a large range
of functions
through these three different structures
it's very dynamic it changes okay you've
got lots of movement and changing and
assembly and disassembly in all of these
components
it's also
a protein
based network so all of these the the
microfilaments the intermediate
filaments the microtubules these are all
proteins or made of proteins filaments
made of proteins so it's this big
network it fills the cells cytoplasm
remember the cytoplasm is really
everything outside the nucleus so the
cytoskeleton all of the sort of aqueous
components and dissolved components in
the cytosol
the organelles all of that is the
cytoplasm so this right here is filling
up that area
also the cytoskeleton fulfills many
different roles and we'll be talking
about roles specific to the
microfilaments which are also called
actin filaments uh the intermediate
filaments and the microtubules we'll
talk about those roles specifically but
you'll start to see
um
several major trends you'll see that
supporting cell
cell shape sort of supporting the
overall cell
transport cell division these are all
rules that are going to come up a few
times
so with that let's go ahead and get
started we're going to start with the
smallest of the three filament types
those are the micro filaments
these are roughly on the order of 7
nanometers
in
in diameter so 7 nanometers across
these are also called
actin
filaments
because they are composed of the monomer
actin specifically
what we call
g-actin
so here g-actin g stands for globular
so globular active these are the
monomers they are assembled polymerized
into two twisted chains kind of like a
double helix sort of like the shape of
dna but not quite
uh so into two twisted chains to make
what we call an f
actin
polymer
so remember that g stands for globular f
stands for filament so it's like the
globular form of actin it's like the
monomers the filament form of actin is
the polymer and this happens via
dehydration synthesis if you would like
to know more about how dehydration
synthesis reactions work check out my
video on that topic
now let's talk about some functions of
microfilaments or actin filaments the
first that we're going to discuss is
muscle contraction
and this is via a protein called myosin
that can basically walk along the
filaments and cause muscles to contract
another major function of microfilaments
is maintenance of cell shape
and support
and we're going to see this
really throughout these functions that
providing shape and support to the
cellular structure is a big part of the
cytoskeleton
kind of hints its name right remember
prefix cyto means cell
skeleton we think of the skeleton as an
internal thing providing support and
certainly that's what these different
cytoskeletal elements do
the next function we'll talk about for
these microfilaments is amoeboid
movement
now if you have heard of like a me bee
an amoeba or plural amidi you know that
it's something you know it's a kind of a
unicellular organism that kind of looks
like that it's um
it's a eukaryotic organism so we're
going to draw a little nucleus in there
and there are different species that
that have like an amoeba-like structure
so if you've ever seen these these are
maybe the way they will
move they kind of
flow
from one place to another and that is
the amoeboid movement and lots of
different cells
can have this kind of movement not just
a meaty even within humans our white
blood cells can move via amoeboid
movement and this amoeboid movement is
kind of flowing or streaming along is
made possible
by cytoplasmic
streaming
and this is really cool to see
so it's just kind of like where one edge
of the cell
everything kind of all of the cytoplasm
um
is sort of flowing in that direction
and that involves constructing
microfilaments on one side of the cell
while tearing them down or disassembling
them on the other side of the cell to
kind of get the cell to move
via that cytoplasmic streaming in that
characteristic amoeboid movement
another
function for microfilament is
intracellular
transport
of
vesicles via again this myosin protein
we'll see this is not the only way that
vesicles can move they can also move the
microtubules that we'll talk about in a
little bit
there's also two other
major forms of
activity at the plasma membrane that
involve microfilaments
and that is
endocytosis
and
exocytosis now endocytosis is one word
exocytosis is one word
i'm just filling in the prefixes here so
please don't make the mistake of
thinking those are separate words
because endocytosis all one word
exocytosis all one word
endocytosis is when something
is brought into the cell from the
extracellular environment i have some of
that drawn right here either a vesicle
carrying some components might merge
with the cell membrane or the cell might
actually kind of take a gulp or take a
bite
of what is in its extracellular
environment and bring that in and that
is known as endocytosis
exocytosis is when something that's
already in the cell the cell wants to
get rid of it so it's packaged into a
vesicle and then ultimately the vesicle
merges with the plasma membrane to
release the components
of that vesicle into the extracellular
space
and so
microfilaments really help to mediate
these processes and the final function
we're going to talk about for these
microfilaments
is formation of the contractile ring
which is shown here in red during
cytokinesis
so remember that cytokinesis is a sage
and cell division that follows mitosis
so mitosis is division of the nucleus
and then you've got cytokinesis which is
division of the cytoplasm so i've drawn
here the separating chromosomes um both
moving you know these chromosomes moving
to either side of this dividing cell
and the contractile ring that forms in
the middle that helps to form that
cleavage furrow
during cytokinesis to split this cell
into two independent cells
though that contractile ring is made of
microfilaments
so now we'll move on to the
second type of cytoskeleton element that
we're going to talk about today it's the
one that is intermediate in size so not
the smallest not the largest but the
intermediate hence their name
intermediate filaments and they tend to
have diameters
from about 8 to 12 nanometers
now these intermediate filaments there
are definitely different types of them
so these are coils of different monomers
remember if you want to
learn more about
monomers
being joined to form polymers check out
that video on dehydration synthesis
reactions i also think i forgot to say
it but i also have a video of about
endocytosis that's why it's in that blue
box which was supposed to remind me to
tell you that i have a video on
endocytosis so check that one out if
you're interested
back to intermediate filaments coils
have different monomers depending on
tissue type or cellular location
so for example in epithelial cells
intermediate filaments are composed of
keratin
monomers
in muscle cells the intermediate
filaments
are composed of monomers called desmonds
and the nuclear lamina which is inside
the nucleus
that is going to be composed of
monomers known as lamins
so depending on where you are in a cell
or an organism those intermediate
filaments can be composed of different
monomers
now let's talk about some of their
functions
like the microfilaments they do
reinforce the cell shape
they also help to anchor
organelles in the
cytoplasm they also form this nuclear
lamina that we were talking about now i
am in the process of preparing a video
on the nuclear lamina odds are by the
time you're watching this that video has
probably already been posted so check
that one out if you want to learn more
about the nuclear lamina the nuclear
envelope and the nucleoplasm and all of
the components of the nucleus
with the intermediate filaments they
form the nuclear lamina we have a
picture of
a nucleus drawn here the green is that
nuclear envelope with the pores in it
the purple that's the chromatin that
sort of dark purple area is meant to be
the nucleolus
but the nuclear lamina which is composed
of these intermediate filaments that's
these pink kind of cross work
mesh of fibers that's drawn right under
there supporting the inside of that
nuclear envelope so the intermediate
filaments they form that nuclear lamina
and that really lends a lot of support
right there's that word support again
support support support big feature of
the cytoskeleton so the lamins that make
up the nuclear lamina
uh they support the nucleus and help
regulate nuclear processes
uh intermediate filaments also form some
not all okay but
some sell sell
and sell
matrix connections so intermediate
filaments can be a way through which a
cell forms connections like physical
connections with neighboring cells
one example of that
is
desmosomes
and i have a diagram of desmosomes drawn
right here so this whole thing
is basically one desmosome in purple
i've got two adjacent cellular membranes
so this would be you know
one cell
and this would be another separate cell
so those two purple lines are the
cellular cell membranes of adjacent like
neighboring cells
you can see in red we've got some
plaques and green coherent proteins
which are like adhesion proteins between
cells but connected to
this um this connection on either side
are these keratin-based intermediate
filaments these would be in epithelial
cells
and so this is how two neighboring
epithelial cells can basically hold
hands
it's a excuse me it's a physical
connection between neighbors so you can
think of it as like two two neighboring
cells holding hands and forming this
this junction through which they can
kind of communicate
okay so now that we have finished up
intermediate filaments let's move on to
the
third type of cytoskeletal element and
this is the microtubules these are the
largest somewhere
on the order of 23 to 27 nanometers
these are hollow tubes hollow
the inside
of the microtubules is known as the
lumen
so these are hollow tubes of tubulin
dimers
tubulin tubulin here is the monomer
uh and then these are dimers they're
composed of two different forms of
tubulin there is the alpha tubulin
and the beta tubulin so those are greek
letters alpha tubulin beta tubulin they
come together to form
a tubulin dimer
and then multiple tubulin dimers make up
microtubules these microtubules are
organized by centrosomes
i didn't really mention it over here but
in
um in cells you've got the centrosomes
i've got one drawn on either side
these are a pair of centrioles organized
at a right angle to each other
and this is where microtubules are
are organized
and so while i was previously pointing
out the contractile ring in red these
dotted lines right here that are pulling
those chromosomes to either side of the
dividing cell those dotted lines are
actually microtubules
so um so organized by those centrosomes
and then it's i think this is fantastic
this is my favorite part of the whole
video
when you have microtubules
switch from
being polymerized so tubulin dimers
being
put together to grow the microtubule to
grow this hollow tube
when it switches from polymerization to
depolymerization to the
disassembly of the microtubule that is
it has an awesome name it is called
catastrophe so that's its scientific
name so it's called
catastrophe
now i have this box in blue not because
i have a video of this but because there
is another video that you should
absolutely check out it was made several
years ago it's quite an old video now by
harvard i think it might have had some
hhmi funding not quite sure about that
but it's called inner
life
of a
cell
i really love this video i always show
it to my students and it shows a
computer
modeling of what this catastrophe event
looks like so i will link to it in the
description below and make sure you
check it out because it's awesome
now if we get to our functions of
microtubules they also help to maintain
cell shape
and give the cell support
so you know we've seen that with
all of these different types of
cytoskeleton
they also make up tracks for moving
vesicles and organelles via two motor
proteins there are
dyna ends
and kinesins
i've got kinesins boxed here because
they also feature in this inner life of
the cell so you can actually see i've
drawn it here kinesin
a motor protein
carrying and it looks like it almost
looks like a person like it like it it's
almost like it's got two arms and two
legs which is awesome it has basically
it's two arm domains holding on to a
massive massive vesicle and it's two
um other domains that look kind of like
feet they can like look like they're
walking down the microtubule highway
it's really really cool to see so make
sure you check out that inner life of
the cell video
there's also chromosome movement via the
mitotic spindle
and that's really what's being shown
over here again the red is the
contractile ring composed of
microfilaments that is kind of helping
to pinch that
cell into two daughter cells during
cytokinesis
but this right here this mitotic spindle
is composed of microtubules that attach
to the chromosomes to help
pull them to opposite sides of that
dividing cell
during mitosis
and so that microtubule structure is
called the mitotic spindle
microtubules also form the cores of
cilia
and
flagella
to allow for beating motility so i have
some of this drawn here too we've got
some of the epithelial cells that line
the respiratory tract otherwise called
the respiratory epithelium
and they
have cilia on them that are drawn here
in green
and though cilia create kind of this
beading wave like
movement i feel like i'm doing a hula
dance or something here
but they they push
basically um mucus that so you've got um
some guard cells in your respiratory
tract that produce mucus to trap like
pollen and dirt and dust that you inhale
and the cilia have this beating
wave-like kind of movement to move that
mucus kind of up up so you
cough you cough all that pollen or dust
out so the cilia are very important to
our respiratory tracts um in fact people
with cystic fibrosis they have a
mutation that interferes with this
process um
leading to um to sort of damage and
problems with their with their
respiratory tract
and then of course flagella flagella
would be like on the human sperm that
have this kind of um whip-like motion so
that the sperm can travel
um kind of up the fallopian tubes right
to meet the egg to have fertilization
and creation of a new human
so
the cilia and the flagella the way that
these things work their cores are
composed of microtubules
so that was a lot for today if you
haven't already make sure you hit
subscribe because i'm always coming out
with new biology study videos i've also
got some of those other videos that i
already mentioned you might want to
check out things like dehydration
synthesis and hydrolysis reactions
endocytosis
um i'm coming up with one here just in
the next week about the nuclear
nucleus including the nuclear lamina and
then that inner life of the cell you
know it's not mine but i just love it i
think it's fabulous so do yourself a
favor and watch it too
um hit subscribe and i will see you next
time thank you very much for watching
biology professor bye